[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue pensez vous que le
duel macron le pen est terminée on en
débat
comme chaque mardi avec alexis brézet
directeur des rédactions du figaro pont
soir à l'existence pharma sa est ce soir
avec philippe meyer créateurs sur le web
du site le nouvel esprit public.fr tout
ça tout attaché dernière émission en
date sur la tournée byden en europe et
sur la présence de la france au sel je
vous propose de revenir sur d'autres
questions brûlantes ce soit une autre
question brûlante ce soir c'est le
phénomène majeur de cette de ce premier
tour l'abstention quasiment record
comment faire revenir les français aux
urnes et bien j'attends vos solutions
vos commentaires messieurs et les vôtres
chers internautes puis on va en débattre
mais d'abord donc hormis en nouvelles
aquitaine et en guadeloupe la république
en marche et par toute la traîne et on
le répète depuis dimanche la
contre-performance du rassemblement
national ne lui permet guère d'espérer à
l'heure où on se parle de remporter une
des super régions en lice ajoutez à cela
la performance de la droite
la résistance de la gauche il n'en faut
pas plus à olivier faur très critiquée
longtemps à la tête du parti socialiste
pour s'offrir cette espérance il ya un
possible qui s'est ouvert dimanche
on nous a conditionné avec cette idée
qui serait une idée indépassable on
n'aurait pas d'autre choix que d'avoir
ce duel entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen et d'un seul coup on se rend
compte que la non c'est pas vrai aux
municipales aux départementales aux
régionales le choix ses pentes emmanuel
macron et marine le pen le choix centre
des offres politiques différentes avec
des gens qui vont peut-être incarner ce
renouveau nous en avons tellement besoin
et à droite nous dit sur twitter
olivier la remarquable performance de
xavier bertrand et de laurent wauquiez
donne l'espoir d'un autre duel que
l'éternel macron le pen tant promis par
les médias est ce que alexis vous
partagez ce pronostic
rare que chan en accord écoliers forme
la semaine cirque il n'a pas tort parce
que c'est vrai que qu'est-ce qu'on n'a
pas entendu depuis des semaines et des
semaines et des mois et des mois sur le
duel macron le pen le pen macron le pen
macron macron le pen de sondage en
sondage avec dire ce paradoxe que chaque
fois qu'un sondage qu'ils arrivaient en
tête l'un et l'autre et dans demon's
crest second tour et chaque fois comment
les aux gens est ce que vous voulez de
ce duel et j'en dis non non on n'en veut
pas mais n'en voulait pas mais crée les
conditions que ce duel ait lieu
et évidemment chacun des deux joueurs
avaient intérêt à ce que cette idée
s'impose parce qu'évidemment politique
les ya un moment où les sensations des
sentiments deviennent des faits et à
force de les répéter de l'est martelé et
donc macro est tout à fait intérêt et
continue d'avoir intéresse qu on dise
qu'il y aura marine le pen car il est le
meilleur belge devant marine le pen
marine le pen a intérêt à dire que la
sentra macron car elle seule est capable
de battre emmanuel macron est donc bon
et puis c'est vrai que d'élections
locales et c'est pas la première fois
alors c'est vrai qu'au municipal s'était
dit lui ai parlé de l'aspect municipal
justement du scrutin local local est bon
là c'est vrai qu'on se rend compte que
nos deux duellistes et nos deux
finalistes
il y en a le front social qui fait au
niveau national 18% lors qu'il ya en
2015 dit et 28% c'est quand même c'est
quand même un tiers du poids relatif qui
disparaît dans la bataille c'est un très
gros recul c'est pas une petite
contre-performance c'est vraiment un
gros recul du front national ça fait pas
beaucoup 18% et quant au parti du
président le parti majoritaire il fait
10 % en moyenne nationale
il est absent d'un grand nombre de
régions second tour notamment
rhône-alpes si je ne trompe pas bonnel
il fait moins de 10 et les autres france
et dans les autres france vient d'avoir
déserté ses affinités et dans les eaux
france où il y avait les cinq ministres
du gouvernement il n'arrive même pas à
franchir avoir des poussins c'est le
parti du président un pdc le parti dit
majoritaire qui fait 10 % des votants 10
% des exprimés
ça veut dire 3 % des inscrits cirque
aujourd'hui quand vous croisez 100
personnes dans la rue il y en a trois
qui ont voté pour nous que je tiens mais
le maquereau ça veut pas dire on va y
venir évidemment que macro ne peut pas
être au second tour la présentielle du
coup marine le pen peut pas y être mais
ça veut dire quand ou cali nu les cte
habilités de ceux du
aujourd'hui elle est absolument remise
en question c'est notre point de vue je
suis plus réservé d'abord quand
j'entends monsieur faure dire on nous a
conditionné il me semble qu'il a un trou
de mémoire parce que il sait très bien
conditionner lui même et tout le monde
sait très bien conditionnés dans cette
idée que le et que ce qu'on entendait
d'ailleurs de la part de ceux qui
aujourd'hui disent ah on nous a
conditionné en fait on arrive c'était il
faut absolument empêcher que y ait ces
deux finalistes deuxième tour dont
qu'ils y croyaient alors il n'y croit
plus aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils ont
raison de ne plus y croire
il ya un phénomène qu'on ne pourra pas
changer ce sont les listes qui ont été
éliminés par exemple dans les hautes
france où là il se passe quelque chose
de tout à fait intéressant et peut être
important autour de xavier bertrand je
dis peut-être important parce que il
faut aussi savoir ce qui va arriver à
valérie pécresse au deuxième tour il
faut d'ailleurs entre parenthèses ne pas
oublier deux choses dans l'analyse de ce
scrutin la première c'est qu'un deuxième
tour et la deuxième c'est l'abstention
dont vous ne comptez nous faire parler
tout à l'heure ceux qui ont fait les
scores dont on vient de parler l'ont
fait sur 30 % de votants ou à peu près
je ne suis pas du tout sûr que ça veut
dire grand chose et que ou bien il ya
une répétition de cette abstention
et dans ce cas là en effet les chiffres
du premier tour sont une indication
intéressante
ou bien il ya tout à coup quelqu'un
enfin au but lac où les gens se disent à
zut quand même non là on aurait quand
même dû y aller
ils vont ne serait-ce que si on double
le nombre des votants se seraient
considérables ça peut apporter des
changements également considérables donc
je suis un peu étonné à la fois de
l'absence de mémoire c'est ce que je
disais à propos de l'évier fort est en
même temps de la façon de se précipiter
dans des prévisions dont on oublie que
comme disait pierre de pierre dac il
faut se garder de ses prévisions quant
elle concerne la vidéo vous avez raison
rien n'est impossible et notamment pas
ce duel mais quand vous dites ça ne veut
pas dire grand chose vous avez raison
mais ça ne veut pas rien dire non plus
ça veut quand même dire quelque chose et
surtout j'ajouterai que même en dehors
du fait que ça veuille ou dire ou ne pas
dire
cela produit des effets oui c'est à dire
clairement les perceptions deviennent
des faits en politique
et donc le simple fait que ce scrutin
ait lieu va changer en partie les choses
au delà même de la question à savoir
s'il est représentatif de quelque chose
ou non c'est à dire que à partir
d'aujourd'hui on le voit déjà
aujourd'hui il ya le nombre et le démon
du doute qui est en train de 2,2 de
s'insinuer notamment dans l'électorat de
marine le pen il dit on va jamais arrivé
mais franchement ça marche jamais on a
essayé la dernière fois il ya cinq ans
alors il était radical elle elle voulait
tout casser et puis on n'a pas voulu là
elle se fait toute la ronde et les
angles ce fait toute banale et on ne
veut toujours pas donc ça va produire un
effet possible qui est un effet de
découragement chez le ch et les
partisans de marine le pen il ya un
autre effet dans l'électorat des
meilleurs mc on doute il faut bien voir
que pour une grande partie
une partie est composée d'un lectorat
qui adhèrent à mâcon mais qui est une
partie assez minime qui est toujours les
son socle de 1er tour il n'a pas élargi
son score de premier tour mâcon l'autre
l'autre partie lectorat connectera
résignés ou utilitaire qui se dit on on
prend macron parce qu'il nous permet de
faire barrage au front national puis à
personne d'autre messi se répand l'idée
un peu plus besoin de faire barrage au
front national parce que plus de faire
barrage au front national il est vrai ou
fausse peu importe je les fait qu'elle
se répande et 2,6 serait pas l'aider
mais après tout la droite peut gagner
tout un tas d'électeurs qui au qui
aurait prévu sans cela d'aller sur mâcon
peuvent se dire en peinture pourquoi pas
puisque toute façon on n'est pas très
attaché à ce mac on ignore donc ce
scrutin la peut produire des effets au
delà même de la de sa valeur intrinsèque
bon je suis d'accord sur l'idée que ces
effets existe et qu'il faut les
surveiller de près ça peut donner
beaucoup de choses il ya aussi quelque
chose qui me paraît intéressant dans ce
résultat surtout s'il est peu ou prou
confirmé et même peu je pense ça
suffirait c'est que du coup ça va
conduire le président de la république à
changer le type de campagne à laquelle
il avait pensé c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir qu'ils avancent sous son drapeau
et non pas sous le drapeau de ces mois
qui suit la jeanne d'arc qui va empêcher
le front national et je vais les buttes
et en dehors du système électoral
du coup
ça veut dire que il devra à ce moment-là
annoncé ce qu'il compte faire dans la
deuxième d'ordre c'est à dire la
deuxième partie dans le deuxième
quinquennat quinquennat il y a et si
c'est le cas je pense que ça sera une
bonne chose pour la campagne c'est c'est
très intéressant car effectivement là je
vous reçu absolument maintenant a perdu
ce qui étaie ses deux béquilles une
béquille qui était donc tu savais déjà
qu'elle était très fragile et finalement
qu'elle marchait quasiment pas c'était
là bas et qui de son parti et malgré
tout dans une bataille avoir un parti
c'est pas tout à fait inutile ce qui n'a
plus de parti il sera seul
donc ça c'est déjà un point important
et puis il sait aussi que maintenant il
va falloir c'est ce que ce que vous
disiez va falloir qu'ils aillent sur ses
propres idées parce que la béquille qui
était de dire je suis le rempart contre
le front national
même si c'était vrai ça va être de moins
en moins cru ça va être de moins en
moins cru parce que le péril du front
national est moins grand et sa capacité
des risques d'y résister à part elle
même moins grandes qui va obliger de ça
le renvoi lui-même à sortir de lui-même
une vérité qui peut être c'est que ça
c'est une épreuve de vérité qui peut se
solder effectivement par quelque chose
de très fort ou au contraire
d'effondrement si au fond la matière
intérieur est pas suffisant vous disiez
tout à l'heure j'entends bien les
perceptions sont des faits néanmoins
d'abord quand on regarde les courbes de
popularité des manuels macron celles qui
sont établies établis notamment par
quand on va les regarder pour le figaro
magazine
elle reste quand même relativement haute
celle de marine le pen était pas basse
non plus
également déjà est ce que c'est un atout
et dans l'autre côté est ce que il n'y a
pas non plus hein quand on va voir les
configurations vous olivier faure ce
soit on voit en voile et pécresse il
pécresse barrois bertrand versus
wauquiez et c est ce que il n'y a pas
non plus un risque de revenir à la case
départ à ce qui avait occasionné
occasionné bien sûr forme de dégage des
raisons c'est évidemment plus amusant de
chercher l'élément nouveau qui va
changer la donne après la donne elle
peut aussi rester telle qu'elle est
parce que déjà il faut que l'on parle de
la gauche mais ce que la gauche est en
est capable de dégager en son sein avec
trois partis eux mêmes divisés un tir de
chaque partie de dégager un candidat
unique qui ferait l'unité de la gauche
franchement je n'en crois pas un instant
je crois que personne n'y croit
maintenant la droite est ce que la
droite va être capable en son sein de se
mettre d'accord de dégager un candidat
peut-être qu'elle finira par y arriver
est ce qu'en dira une incarnation
suffisante pour parler électorat de
droite s qui trouvera le discours le
programme qui va qui va susciter
l'adhésion
tout ça est très très fragile et on peut
tout à fait vous avez raison se
retrouver avec un maquereau qui fort de
la popularité qui s'attachent finalement
à ça la stature présidentielle qu'on lui
conteste pas et une marine le pen qui
sortent sur la colère des français qui
réel on en reparlera moins de
l'abstention
ils peuvent tout à fait se retrouver au
second tour je dis pas du tout que c'est
impossible je dis juste que s'ouvre
quelque chose qui permet de dire que ça
n'est pas obligé et de simple fait de
dire que c'est pas obligé change la
donne voilà tout ce que je veux dire
alors je suis d'accord que il arrive
souvent que les perceptions soit des
faits il arrive aussi que les
perceptions soit des miroirs aux
alouettes
je pense notamment à ce qui est en train
de se passer à gauche où tout à coup là
l'image donnée d'unités exceptionnel à
travers notamment l'ile-de-france ne
nous croyez pas la dynamite en ile de
france
non à la dynamique de la gauche en ile
de france non non non je forcément il va
y avoir un peu plus de voix cette fois
ci parce qu'il faudra bien trouver
encore que d'ailleurs pas sûrement oui
parce que les gens j'étais en train de
de gaulle un retrait paraît très à
gauche pour la sociologie francilienne
l'offre politique en ile de france et on
notera que manuel valls ne soutient pas
notamment cette liste pour vous
rappelant le caractère des deux gauches
ans qui courait consignables oui
ajoutez à ça que d'ici la fin de la
campagne
chacune des composantes de la gauche va
quand même essayer de tirer la
couverture à elle pour expliquer que
c'est elle qui a traîné tout le monde
est qui et qui a gagné et que si on en
juge par essentiellement je dirais les
comportements récente julien bayou et
deux autres plus ample et audrey pulvar
ils sont très capables de dire d'ici
dimanche des bêtises tels que ça
décourage un certain nombre de gens mais
je voudrais faire juste une petite
hypothèse un peu un retour en arrière
baissé sur le sur le front national est
ce que il n'ya pas quelque chose j'avais
suggéré ça ici la dernière fois que
j'étais venu mais ce cas pas quelque
chose qui fait que les gens qui sont qui
disent que marine le pen à leurs voeux
leurs suffrages mais qui ne votent pas
pour le front national qui n'ont pas
voté pour le front national ce qui sont
pas en train de se rendre compte qu'au
temps de marine le pen ya personne il ya
personne n'est que quand on voit marine
le pen entouré de ses lieutenants et
qu'on essaye de transposer ça en une
photo de gouvernement à la sortie de
l'elysée on se dit non
franchement non ça tient pas la route ça
tient pas la route
mais là en l'occurrence il avait à voter
pour mariani en paca si un ministre et
un ancien ministre qui est peut-être pas
le
je lui demande de quoi il a été ministre
vous ils sont vous vous en souvenez pas
non plus donc ya pas tellement de raison
bon gars au en occitanie députés
rdr à la demande est libre et ump ump
ensuite légèrement mais qui est pas non
plus bon bon après il y en a certains
qui sont effectivement plus fragiles
et comme disait ma grand mère y en a
beaucoup qui n'ont pas mordu les rues ce
désir là c'est sûr mais est ce que c'est
ça ça peut être ça me semblerait plus
vrai dans une passe au niveau
présidentiel
là j'ai moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment
mais je sais des hypothèses on en est
réduit aux hypothèses que marine le pen
à force de à force de vouloir se dit
dédiaboliser ce qu'elle fait avec succès
a fini par se banaliser et que tous tout
un électorat qui au fond l'utiliser
comme support d'une colère etc ça
souvent ces votes anti système c'est
votre populisme c'est votre extrémistes
peu importe le nom dont on est dans
lequel on les nomme
c'est l'expression d'une colère c'est de
la transgression c'est on va leur donner
une bonne claque
mais si le héros de ceux de ce parti là
devient si arrondi à ce point les angles
devient si policé que finalement nous
dit ben al islam est pas un problème de
religion que c'est un poème vidéo logis
nous dit l'europe va pas sortir nous dit
la dette en valeur en bourse et je vous
demande dans quelle mesure à force de
ce2 ce2 se
dédiaboliser c'est pas banaliser et
qu'elle souffrait pas ses papiers elle
même il n'a pas démobilisé secteur on va
on va revenir justement ce mais ça ne
veut pas dire qu est-ce qui se
mobiliseront pas une autre fois où ils
iront que l'enjeu en vaut la peine il
faut aussi prendre en compte on va en
parler quand de la dimension régionale
justement on va on va reparler juste une
dernière question sur macron justement
est ce que là aussi on l'a on là où la
vie sur la personnalité de macron mais
est ce que le mal lrm n'arrive pas à
être crédible en tout cas au niveau
local mais est ce que le maquereau nisme
lui est dans le même état
où est ce qu'il peut être remplacée je
sais pas par le bertrand 10 mhz le bar
one is mlle plus précis je suis ça
écoute c'est bien il ya une spécificité
macro il ya une chose du président que
je comprends pas c'est pourquoi ayant
toutes les informations qu'il peut avoir
il a persisté à envoyer autant de poids
lourds au front pour des résultats qui
sont à ce point médiocre y compris du
plus capé d'entre eux marc fesneau qui
se traîne et ça qu'elle est franchement
quelle quel peut être l'intérêt alors
qu'on imagine qu'une élection où il n'y
aurait eu que des locaux comme candidat
puisque sont des élections locales
départementales et régionales
là il est bon bah coudes et nous en
sommes au début de notre implantation on
a des résultats qui sont pas mauvais
pour des gens qui débutent
mais bon il laissait ses ministres
travail et je comprends pas ça je
comprends pas ça c'est cette foi qui lui
conseille ça aussi c'est lui même qui ce
conseil mais ça me laisse un peu pantois
de une bourde de cette nature en tout
cas c'est une bonne politique peut-être
qu'il y au fait qu'il n'ait pas
d'expérience de la politique
politicienne sans doute il ya eu aussi
des conseilleurs qui ont peu été très
bien inspiré et qu' il s'est dit qu'à
lui seul il
résoudre une situation relever un défi
alors que personne ne demandait qu
effectivement ceux retenus les car ils
ont très bien tiré pour répondre à votre
question je crois pas qu'ils de
maquereaux nisme le maquereau nice on le
voit n'existe pas il n'ya pas de parti
maurice il ya macron mais macron c'est
quelque chose et aujourd'hui macron ça
pèse plus lourd que bertrand où ça pèse
plus lourd que les grèves ça me le logo
de marque on sait qu'il est tout seul
mais c'est aussi une c5
la présidentielle c'est un homme qu'on
élit donc il faut pas non plus jeter
l'eau avec du bain soudain pratique
virons dit l'arrêt mais battue dont qui
enfin dire parce que la relève est tu
diriges être battu par dont il est élu
sur la même et il peut être réélu sans
la même mais je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord
enfin alexis dit son problème c'est
qu'il est tout seul c'est aussi son acte
mais celui qui est en face que ce soit
vous ne saviez bertrand que ce soit
celle qui est en face valérie pécresse
ou peut-être quelqu'un d'autre qui a
évoqué ses invoqué à l'intérieur de leur
formation politique ou de le ler
politique dans laquelle ils évoluent ça
va être le la haine vigilante et les
peaux de banane en veux tu en voilà
macron il a comptes à l'intérieur de ses
partisans il ya que lui puis le
président sortant ce qui m'avait il est
ouvert mais de les capitaliser
oui d'offrir une dynamique ne le duel
existe au niveau national mais pas local
estime françois vole pas où nous avons
vu enfin qu'il n'y a pas que macro et le
pen mais les jeux ne sont pas faits ces
régionales montre que tout peut se
passer en 2022 estime que si un nouveau
parti politique apparaît en 2022 il
risque de faire un malheur et babineau
le raz-de-marée de l'abstention brouille
les pistes il faut être prudent avant de
tirer des conclusions active et bien
merci beaucoup parce que vous nous
offrez parfaitement la transition tout
comme
alex qui me disaient faire un
rapprochement entre les résultats des
régionales avec celui des
présidentielles serait très maladroit
car les enjeux ne sont pas les mêmes et
il ya encore presque un an avant les
élections mais il faut que vous combien
face faut bien faire une photographie un
petit peu du rapport des forces
sir alex pour pouvoir effectivement
aussi se projeter
on a posé la question quand même un sur
twitter pensez vous que le régional de
2021 marque la fin du duel annoncé
macron le pen et vous répondez non à 62%
l'autre question qu'on me pose sur
twitter c'est si les français peuvent
pensez vous que les français vont
continuer massivement à s'abstenir aux
élections il